15 of the visser countries in europe and
central asia
hef close report occasions of to a
crown
this is quickly become in the
dumber dwarres in western europe
en tisno spreading into the balkans
it is know the institute for money
zipped and evaluation
for closet
that more  than fifty percent of the
population angry de baby in fact the love
for a crown in the next six to eight
weeks
the omicron variant' represents a new
west to east tidal wave
sweeping a scratch reason to top of the
delta search that also includes a quiz for
managing a late 20 can your on
how something can you rhino the sponge must be in
forms at is epidemic pink pillow to
point and many bureau sources
fractionation upptäck towns and social
economy context
the regions so about 7 million new learning
port it cases or correct my  team in
the first week of twenty twenty two more
than doubling over aid to be quick
d taco suffered it in recent weeks conforms
that om a crown is highly transmission
will be cordemais  party the house and
label i do it here anyway guys even
more easily
and it can effect this those who have
in previously in vector vaccinate it
en louis torii enter that core 3
upload box bye aim continue to
provide good protection against severe
disease and that  coloring for om in
chrome
what bicos or the a president skating
or transmission oui or nothing
rising short my team hospitalizations
this is charging health systems and
service delivery
in many countries where to exchange a crown
hespress out speed and threatens to over
we in many more
honeychurch and relax seventeen
knew had burst and popular
quickly and posing for new challenges
cwc team on the leg able to let and then
i mark my bikram and the neck in joe's
pub and an atom till 2020 your is a
little bit difficult best age i think
new director
sitting a product
I came in the neck in 2020 bon